ينضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور منير شفيق
الكاتب والمفكر
الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك دكتور
منير سابدا معك بتقييم عام لما وصلت اليه
الامور
لتقييم حال المقاومه
وحال الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد مرور شهر على
بدء هذه الحرب واستمرارها
في الحقيقه القراءه العامه للوضع القائم
الان في فلسطين وبصوره خاصه المقصود الان
في قطاع غزه اننا نواجه حربين لا حربا
واحده الحرب الاولى هي حرب المقاومه
والشعب عموما ضد الكيان الصهيوني وضد
الاغتصاب
الصهيوني وهو ما يجري الان في في المعركه
التي تسمى الحرب البريه اما الحرب الثانيه
فهي الحرب التي تشنها امريكا من خلال
الكيان الصهيوني في اباده المدنيين في
قطاع غزه يعني عندنا حرب ويجب ان نفصل
بينهما الحرب الاولى هي حرب المقاومه وحرب
التحرير الحرب الثانيه هي حرب الاباده
الموجهه للمدنيين وللحجر والمستشفيات و كل
ما هو عمراني في قطاع غزه لذلك اعتقد اننا
في الحرب
ال المتعلقه بقتل المدنيين هذه حرب يجب ان
تكون حرب
عالميه ضد امريكا وضد الكيان الصهيوني
باعتبارهما مجرمين مجرمين مباشرين في قتل
المدنيين وفي تدمير البلاد وهذه قضيه تهم
الانسانيه كلها ولا تهم فقط محور المقاومه
او الوطنيين او العرب والمسلمين فقط
وبالتالي يجب ان توقف هذه الحرب علما اننا
حتى في هذه الحرب اعتقد ان امريكا والكيان
الصهيوني اخذا يخسران يوما بعد يوم من
سمعتهما ومن مكانتهما بل اصبحا يهددان
الحضاره الغربيه بدمار كل القيم التي
تحدثت عنها عندما يستهترون الى هذا الحد
بالحرب المدنيه اما الحرب
الاولى وهي حرب المقاومه انا انا ارى ان
التجربه خلال السبعه ايام الماضيه اثبتت
ان الكيان الصهيوني لا يستطيع ان يخترق
بشكل جدي المقاومه والدفاع الذي تقوم به
المقاومه على البر وبالتالي ايضا طريقه ان
يخسر وان تنتصر المقاومه في الحرب البريه
ان يعني ان ي نعم ولكن الجانب الاسرائيلي
والجانب الامريكي بشكل خاص يعني رغم هذا
التقييم الذي تفضلت به بدا يتحدث عن
مستقبل قطاع غزه من دون حركه حماس من دون
فصائل المقاومه منطقه لا تشكل تهديدا
لمستوطنات غلاف غزه ولا لاسرائيل وبالتالي
يتصرف الجانب الامريكي او الجانب
الاسرائيلي باعتباره انه منتصر سلف وهو
يبحث عن سيناريوهات ما بعد الانتصار
والحرب يعني بتعرف اخي عندما يتحدثون ماذا
سيريدون ان يفعلوا في قطاع غزه بعد انتهاء
الحرب انا بعتقد انهم يقومون بتجربه يعني
هيك كلعبه يعني تحذروا فيها اي حرب في
الدنيا ما يجري بعدها هو هو ما تنتهي هي
اليه يجب اولا ان يضمنوا الانتصار بهذه
الحرب حتى يقولوا ماذا سيفعلون وماذا
سيرتب في غزه ولكن لماذا لا يسالون ولا
يضعون يعني خطط ماذا سيحدث اذا هزموا وهو
الاكيد الذي سيحدث في هذه الحرب واذا بقيت
المقاومه وبقيت حماس بعز قوتهما في هذه
الحرب البريه لانه انتبه الحرب البريه هي
تنزل بهم خسائر مستمره الجيش الصهيوني قد
لا يحتملها وكذلك الناس العاديين في
الكيان الصهيوني لن يحتملها انا برايي لا
نتحدث عما سيحدث او عما يسمونه اليوم
التالي الا اذا تاكدنا كيف ستنتهي الحرب
وهي التي تقرر النهايه يعني اينما سيصل
الجندي في في الحالتين هو الذي سيقرر ماذا
سيجري في المرحله اللاحقه الان كل هذا
الكلام الامريكي لا قيمه له ولا لا يساوي
شيئا لانه قبل ان يستولوا على قطاع غزا
كلام فارغ هذا فانا بقول لهم احن الذ اي
نعم ولكن ثمت من يسال هنا هل يعقل هل يعقل
ان تترك الولايات المتحده اسرائيل تخسر
هذه المعركه وهي التي وضعت كل ثقلها اي في
هذه المعركه وبالتالي هناك يعني ليس فقط
الولايات المتحده هناك دعم غربي واضح
واوروبي بشكل خاص لاسرائيل على خلفيه
المصالح المتشابكه والاستراتيجيه معها هل
كل هذا المحور الغربي سيقبل بخساره
اسرائيل في هذه الحرب هذا سؤال يطرحه
الكثيرون نعم
نعم بالمناسبه الذي يقرر من سيربح سيترك
او لا يتركوهم هذا يتعلق في موازين القوى
الان اذا اسفرت المعارك الجاريه الان على
الارض البريه من جهه وكما اذا اسفرت الحرب
الموجهه ضد المدنيين الى خساره عالميه على
امريكا والكيان الصهيوني خرجوا منها
مبهدلين وتحت الاتهام والى اخره واذا
خسروا الحرب البريه او جزء كبير من الحر
البريه شو يعني تحملوا او هل يعقل او لا
لا يعقل يعقل انه ينهزموا ويعقل انه يقروا
بموازين القوى شو بدهم يعملوا الا اذا بدك
تفترض كما اذا افترض هذا المهوس انه يستخم
القبه النب النوويه يعني هم اذا استخدموا
كل قواتهم البريه وقدر وبعد كل هذا القصف
الجنوني طيب ب انا بقول لك يعقل ليش لا
يعقل انهم ينهزموا وهو انهزموا يعني احن
شفناهم حتى بهذه التجربه الجيش الاسرائيلي
يهرول و هاربا في المرحله الاولى ب 7
اكتوبر ليش الان اذا اشتد عليهم الوطيس
وفعلا المقاومه التي تفكر تفكيرا جيدا في
الدفاع
نعم ن نعم لانه فقط باختصار شديد هنا سؤال
ايضا يطرح نفسه من هذه الفرضيه التي تذكرت
او ذكرتها ام هل يمكن بهذا مع هذه النتائج
ان يتوسع اذا الصراع لمنع الخساره
باختصار اكيد اكيد لا احد يستطيع ان يستمر
بالخساره يعني هم سيحاولون وعم حاولوا
والمشكله ان انه كلما خسروا في الميدان
ومش قادرين يحققوا على ارض الميدان
الانتصار لانه الانتصار لا يتشكل بقتل
المدنيين او من خلال الجو الانتصار يتحقق
من خلال البر ومن خلال السيطره على
المواقع التي توجد فيها كل المقاومه في
غزه هذا اذا استحال امامهم وهو
سيستحوذ انا عم ببني على واقع متحقق خلال
الاسبوع الماضي وكيف ماشي الامور يعني انا
لما اشوف كيف شاب ركد وحط متفجر على
الدبابه او كيف طلع فوق كذا
وولعها شكرا لك الكاتب والمفكر الفلسطيني
حدثنا من بيروت